et c'est donc une guerre antidrogue le
ministre de l'intérieur entend mener
outre les actions sur le terrain
réalisée par les forces de l'ordre
gérald darmanin multiplie les sorties
mène la bataille de la communication
alors est-il encore audible dans faîtier
pas trop sur ce thème elle pour en
parler nous sommes avec arnaud benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire bonsoir hameau
benedetti merci d'être avec nous bonsoir
à vos côtés et lexandre langlois
secrétaire général du syndicat policier
vigie bonsoir à vous également alexandre
donc loi alors avant de vous donner la
parole messieurs je voudrais qu'on
écoute les déclarations de gérald
darmanin ce matin et surtout le
vocabulaire employé par le ministre de
l'intérieur nous augmentons le prix du
tabac dans ce gouvernement
on ne va pas légaliser la drogue à côté
on ne va pas dire que le tabac c'est
bien et légaliser la drogue ce qu'il
faut extrêmement souligné c'est qu'il ya
tous les jours des associations des
parents des policiers et des élus locaux
qui luttent contre cet art la drogue
c'est de la loire je le dis avec les
mots de tous les parents que j'ai reçu
dans ma permanence d'élue alors la
parole en tout d'abord un spécialiste de
la communication pour commencer parce
qu'évidemment on n'a pas forcément
l'habitude d'entendre ce genre de deux
mots dans la bouche du patron de la
place beauvau il imprime son stylo
benedetti gérald darmanin
on a beaucoup dit que j'ai encore mal et
était une réplique
quelques années plus tard de nicolas
sarkozy qui lui aussi avait été un
usager de parler cash dé vous quand il
dénoncé les racailles qui le promettait
de l'est de les nettoyer au cash au
karcher donc on est là disons dans une
eau d'une ligne politique qui vise
finalement à bordés à droite
si vous voulez gérald darmanin c'est
l'homme qui est là pour dans la macro ni
actuellement montrer que l'on entend un
certain nombre de préoccupations des
électrices et des électeurs de droite
donc il est ce flotteur de droite de
cette majorité qui vit
à évoquer la figure qui pour certains
est une figure nostalgique pour certains
militants et parfois sur certains
électeurs et électrices de la droite
républicaine de nicolas sarkozy donc il
est dans ce rôle
c'est un choix de communication alors
vous le policier alexandre langlois
quand vous entendez votre ministre
parler sur ce ton vous vous dites ça y
est on est on est sauvé quelqu'un décidé
de prendre en main de problème je crois
que les mots étaient bien dit par
volonté l'intervenant qu'avec moi c'est
un choix de communication nous sommes
dans la communication
on pense qu'on a déjà vécu ça avec
monsieur sarkozy qui avait été doublé
avec la politique du chiffre et pour le
moment on a eu beaucoup de
gesticulations on a eu beaucoup de
choses et là en plus nous avons une
copie de monsieur sarkozy soutient qu'on
garde la copie est souvent moins bien
que l'original donc même pour les
ostalgiques ce sera pas du tout pareil
donc pour le moment on a beaucoup de
gesticulations l'année dernière monsieur
castaner avait inauguré l'eau fasse un
nouvel office pour lutter contre la
drogue et en rassemblant plusieurs
services ils avaient dit qu'il y aurait
plus de monde dans le service et comme
il avait pris des des douaniers des
gendarmes et de différentes unités
finalement au final y avait moins de
monde qu'à l'origine donc en mutualisant
les moyens donc pour le moment on n'est
pas bien sûr que ça va changer grand
chose au final
alors testons communication on peut se
poser la question à nos bd betty est ce
que finalement le style darmanin ça
marche
acquis par le tilt précisément aux
policiers on voit pas à tous les
policiers en tout cas on français il
parle il parle bien évidemment d'abord
aux françaises et aux français
ceci dit le premier front qui était
celui de gérald darmanin quand il est
arrivé le plat pauvre c'était d'essayer
de réconcilier le ministre de
l'intérieur avec un corps social la
police qui considérait que dans les
toutes dernières séquences notamment
après le déconfinement elle avait été
maltraitée par son ministre est donc le
premier objectif c'était 7
j'allais dire cette première ligne de
front ensuite il ya eu tout un contexte
durant l'été d'événements qui ont
particulièrement marqué l'actualité où
on a
vu progressivement l'enjeu sécuritaire
qui avait un peu disparu du fait du du
conflent réapparaître dans l'agenda
politique donc on a un ministre de
l'intérieur qui au regard de 7,1 je veux
montrer qu'il occupe le poste qu'ils
entretiennent discours à la fois
d'autorité et de fermeté pour tout
simplement défendre l'ordre public
si toutes ses formes alors allez
sanglant on a compris que vous adhérez
pas nécessairement à ce style darmanin
vous parliez de son hyper communication
en fait voilà son style proche de
sarkozy mais voilà peut-être en moins
bien si je prend vos mots vous disiez
tout de même que ça imprime chez
certains policiers
c'est un petit peu mieux que ce qu'ils
au castanet avons moins pire si j'ose
dire pour vous dire qu'on avait touché
le fond et monsieur k ster on peut que
remonter
je rappelle que le dieu castaner les
policiers lui en veulent beaucoup pour
sa gestion des masques aux et qui nous
avait soufflé pour le colis de ces
gesticulations diverses et variées et le
soupçon avéré qui a été vraiment pas
passé donc effectivement on pouvait
difficilement faire pire que monsieur
castaner monsieur darmana par contre
gesticule beaucoup fait beaucoup de
communication mais au final qu'est ce
qui va se passer dans la réalité les
policiers ne sont pas multiplient comme
des petits pains les policiers seront
utilisés qu'on a pu voir encore ce
week-end contre des manifestations les
encadre très lourdement par rapport au
nombre de manifestants dire que ça
pendant ce temps là ils ne sont pas
ailleurs à lutter contre le trafic de
stupéfiants
la deuxième chose également c'est qu'on
nous demande de lutter pour faire du
chiffre
parce que la politique du chiffre dans
la police nationale n'a pas changé et
même on s'attend que ça va s'amplifier
vu qu'ils veulent publie les chiffres
mensuellement et on va nous demander de
faire du chiffre pour la lutte contre la
drogue
et qu'est ce qu'on fait comment on fait
du chiffre en dressant des
contraventions par exemple pour les
consommateurs de cannabis
pendant ce temps là on ne s'occupe pas
des trafics les policiers sont
demandeurs de démanteler les trafics qui
sont pas demandeur de s'occuper des
boulettes du shit parce qu'ils n'ont pas
pensé révolutionner le pays en faisant
ça ou assurer la sécurité de tout le
monde
ils ont fait des chiffres ils ont
rassuré la coque du gouvernement mais
c'est pas comme ça que les gens vont
vivre sérieusement hockey des policiers
qui savent eux on a des collègues qui
s'avoue sur les cages des fois etc ils
n'ont pas forcément le droit
d'intervenir lors du bal trafic était
l'endroit où on se sent impuissant et
c'est un puissance qu'est révoltante
alors qu'on nous dise finalement fait de
casser les os conservateur le
consommateur passe pour une
contravention très bien encore
qu'ils soient solvables mais ce n'est
pas ça le coeur du métier pourquoi les
policiers seront très on n'est pas
rentré pour faire des auxiliaires des
impôts on est rentré pour mettre les
délinquants et les criminels en prison
un nouvel indice important ce qui nous
dit alex en l'envoi parce qu'en gros il
nous dit voilà il ya de la communication
d'un côté et puis dans le fond c'est où
sont les trafics mais en gros on n'a pas
le droit d'intervenir il ya une vraie
hypocrisie un double langage de la part
du gouvernement
vous savez c'est une des grandes figures
classiques de la critique de la
communication si la communication des
pas suivi d'actes et de moyens associés
à ces actes elle reste forcément de la
communication et c'est bien aujourd'hui
en tout cas une partie des critiques qui
commencent à émerger contre l'action ou
en tout cas la non l'action où l'action
seulement communicante du ministre de
l'intérieur
c'est vrai que il a relevé le niveau
sémantique mais il ne suffit pas de
relever le niveau sémantique
si encore une fois vous ne venez pas des
politiques publiques qui sont conformes
aux mots que vous prononcez et bien vous
êtes malheureusement vraisemblablement
en mesure de décevoir un assez
rapidement et c'est à ce défi
aujourd'hui est confronté un gérald
darmanin qui en plus à un président de
la république qui sur la question
régaliennes a toujours été soupçonnée de
de maîtriser a suffisamment cette
question là d'ailleurs même au moment de
l'élection présidentielle ont crédité
d'une compétence économique world une
volonté réformatrice
emmanuel macron mais on avait des doutes
sur sa capacité en tout cas à 10 ont
mené des politiques régaliennes qui soit
efficace
alors je vous propose justement à
d'écouter notre petite réplique un
prononcé par gérald darmanin smet
quand l'enfant de 14 ans touche plus en
une journée que son père qui travaille à
l'usiné d'à côté on ne peut pas
s'étonner qu'il y ait une crise
d'autorité
alors c'est une petite phrase comme ça
mais alexandre l'envoi il ya quand même
du vrai ce que vous pouvez
j'ai comme une forme de sincérité en
tout cas dans l'eau dans la volonté
votre mise de l'intérieur ça peut faire
changer les esprits quand même on peut
l'espérer en tous les cas après de la
sincérité peut-être pas forcément en
tous les cas une non ces propos là les
derniers c'est assez lucide et c'est a
décidé également c'est qu'on peut
constater qu'il ya deux choses il ya
ceux qui vont tomber par choix dans la
voie de la délinquance parce
qu'effectivement ça paye bien ça
rapporte beaucoup plus donc voila mais
après qu'est ce que font les pouvoirs
publics pour mettre fin à ces personnes
parce qu on est bien d'accord qu'en
s'attaquant aux consommateurs et ne
s'occupe pas de ce qu'ils rapportent de
l'argent derrière la deuxième chose
également c'est que bay aussi un taux de
chômage qui est parallèle dans c dans
certaines dans certains quartiers
difficiles où cité populaire et qui fait
que les pays bas qui subissent pas faut
bien que j'arrive à survivre à tel point
qu'on a vu des collègues qui avaient
démantelé un trafic de stups c'était
sous le quinquennat de monsieur hollande
dans une cité et le mois suivant là on
leur avait fait des pieds et des
citations ce à des prix plus ou moins de
travailler ou le mois suivant leur a dit
oui mais plus personne peut payer son
loyer hlm donc arrêter de démanteler des
trafics et je rappelle qu'en plus ce
pour le pib de la france mettant le
trafic de drogue et dans le pib de la
france donc en plus si rien de sûr
économique qui est intégré donc à toute
cette hypocrisie ce double discours où
on nous dit faites les choses et ne fait
pas à côté de ça et après pour revenir
sur le modèle également une autre
anecdote police sur la politique des
statistiques et du chiffre on avait dans
un commissariat de brigades une brigade
qui s'occupait de la tranquillité
publique qui interpellait des gens qui
étaient nocifs parce que les gens les
appelait pour des agressions et des
choses assez grave
tous les cas qui était pénible pour les
habitants et à côté de ça avait une
autre équipe qui faisait 90 boulette de
shit par mois malheureusement à cause
d'une réduction d'effectifs qui avait eu
du tout monsieur sarkozy une des deux
brigades a fermé on n'a gardé que celle
qu'avaient les meilleures statistiques
sans regarder le contenu comme monsieur
d'art maladie qu'il allait publier les
chiffres mensuels mans n'a peur qu'ils
essaient de course aux chiffres
cette course à la production statistique
et que personne à y regarder ce qu'il ya
dedans alors que malheureusement et des
rapports parlementaires qui montre que
bah c'est un peu le truc à chaque fois
pour faire dire ce qu'on veut à ces
chiffres a renommés nezih le mot de la
fin pour vous cette politique du chiffre
et effectivement on en revient toujours
à lui
ça rappelle un certain nicolas sarkozy
oui mais si vous voulez il ya la
politique du chiffre il ya les données
j'avais dire statistiques
et puis il ya la réalité le telle
qu'elle est vécue et ressentie alors
parfois de manière subjective mais aussi
parfois de manière objective à la fois
par les policiers mais aussi par les
citoyennes et les citoyens et donc c'est
toute la difficulté qui consiste d'un
côté a réaffirmé un discours d'autorité
dans lequel finalement une grande
majorité de nos concitoyens se
retrouveront et ensuite la déclinaison
de cette de cette autorité sur le
terrain avait décliné l'autorité sur le
terrain ce n'est pas seulement se
limiter à des déclarations
c'est encore une fois donné des moyens
comme le réclament les policiers et
surtout ne pas hésiter à mener des
politiques publiques qui soient des
politiques publiques qui met un terme à
une forme d'appauvrissement de l'état à
la réalité c'est que ce que nous vivons
est d'ailleurs gérante armada d par ex
pour saab directement
c'est une politique d'appauvrissement
des moyens publics de l'état et
notamment des moyens régalien la justice
est exactement dans la même situation
voire pire que celle de la police en
l'occurrence et cette politique est
menée depuis très nombreuses années
quelles que soient les majorités et
c'est ce que aujourd'hui renvoie comme
critique tout un ensemble de
fonctionnaires qui sont confrontés à la
réalité du terrain qui doit retraiter et
aussi à la réalité des moyens qui
manquent pour finalement d'une certaine
manière remplir les objectifs que leur
fixe le gouvernement quel qu'il soit
d'ailleurs
merci beaucoup aux benedetti et
alexandre avec nous